To get started on Ketalysis. So one
of the principles of green chemistry,
it's way down there at number nine.
There's clearly a lot of
benefits that can come from it.
And the wording of the
principal is pretty careful.
We'll come back to this selectivity
issue in a minute cause that's pretty
important.
So to figure out whether your processes
really turning out to be green based on
a catalyst or not, you would want to
start out looking at the 12 principal.
It was just kind of go down
the list one through 12. Uh,
is the catalyst toxic or not?
Is it actually used in sub
Stuckey metric amounts?
And that that's a serious
consideration because you,
you'll find in some of the literature
that there are cases where, uh, you know,
even though the substance is not changed
during the course of the reaction that
has to be present in such
a large amount that it,
it's kind of questionable to really call
it a catalyst that on a mass basis it
may actually be more than your reagents.
Um,
so considering 12 principles related
to auxiliaries and special materials,
sometimes using a particular catalyst
might require that you use a toxic
solvent. It might require a
moisture, free conditions,
oxygen free conditions.
All of these things might counteract the
positive benefits that you're getting.
The principles about abundant renewable
resources. You can make catalysts from,
from virtually anything. Uh, then what
happens at the end of the reaction?
Can you reuse it?
Can you separate it from the product?
That's a really big deal in pharmaceutical
chemistry because people taking the
drugs don't want to be taking
random elements from the
periodic table with their
medicine. And then it's very common
that you can add a catalyst, a reaction,
and it might be too good of a catalyst.
It might go uncontrollably generate heat,
uh, generate product too quickly. Um,
we'll come back to that later in the
semester when we talk about chemical
accidents,
but you have to ask all these questions
and then applying these at different
parts of the lifecycle.
So you almost have to consider the
catalyst itself as a chemical product that
you would, you would think
of. Um, ordinarily. So again,
going through the life cycle of
raw materials, manufacturing,
use and end of life.
So when we consider the raw materials,
we've talked a lot about whether
the carbon comes from hydrocarbons,
petroleum fractions,
but also thinking about metals because
virtually anything in the periodic table
can be used in catalysts.
So if you look at a chart of
here are all the elements are,
are lined up in order from
lowest atomic numbers.
So here's hydrogen and lithium all
the way up to the, uh, the higher,
these are 90.
So uranium up in 92.
And you see this sort of general trend
that is you get heavier and heavier that
the abundance goes down quite a lot.
And this is a logarithmic scale.
So there's a difference of at least
nine or 10 orders of magnitude between
something like aluminum and say
Rhodium or palladium osmium.
And so when you do have a choice
and a catalytic system, it may be,
doesn't always make sense to use something
that's only produced on the scale of,
I don't know, a ton per year or
something like, um, you know,
copper or cobalt. These
tend to be produced on the
scale of Giga tons per year.
So the,
the impacts of choosing a particular
element to be in your catalyst are pretty
far reaching.
And some work that came out of the
forestry school here at Yale, uh,
out of Tom gratefuls group. This, this
publication just came out this year.
They did a study on whether certain
elements have good substitutes available.
And the reason for this,
there's a lot of metals have
restrictions on the supply chains there.
There's vulnerabilities to supplies either
for political reasons because certain
countries control access or just abundant
reasons of abundance that there's not
a lot of the stuff in the ground to
begin with. And it turns out for,
for many elements, these ones that
are, that are red, uh, there's,
there's not any other, well, right now
at least there's not any other, uh,
element or technology that can
replace the use of these metals.
So what that means is if you're tasked
with coming up with a new catalyst,
you might say,
okay,
I have this great manganese catalyst that
I want to use to do biomass conversion.
I'm going to make all this, uh, you know,
useful chemical building block
from a renewable resource.
But if right now manganese is being used
in some other application that can't be
substituted,
then you have to think about is it
pulling away from something that's really
critical? Or You could also use this
as the flip side to say, all right,
well why is,
why is Rhodium so poor in terms of the
available substitutes and that might be a
good area to focus research attention.
Um,
and the interesting thing that,
uh,
also coming out of all work
is that virtually all of
these elements tend to get
used almost in combination.
So something like an iPhone has a,
what does it like 90 or a hundred
different elements in it? So the, um,
it, it's pretty common that
you find technologies that
are hitting a lot of these
red boxes and then you have to start
asking these questions about priority
priority. Do we need
to have, uh, you know,
Europium and our smartphone or do we
need to be saving that Europium for some
other medical use or water
treatment type of views.
So going along the life cycle,
you could think about manufacturing
of the catalyst itself.
So the catalyst doesn't usually does not
just magically come out of the ground
or off of a tree or something.
A lot of catalysts have
very complicated syntheses.
So they take energy to do
the chemical reactions.
There's waste that's associated
with those different reaction steps.
And then you have to consider the toxicity
of the other materials that are going
into the build,
the catalyst.
And then in terms of the use when
you're actually applying the catalysts.
So we talked about selectivity,
is it giving you a good set
of products that you want?
And then you'll see these numbers come
up over and over again in the literature.
And we'll talk about these in
the coming classes as well.
These are basically metrics
on the catalyst performance.
So the first one I think is
pretty, uh, pretty intuitive.
It's just how much product you can
make per mole of catalyst. So that's,
this is the key number that's going
to tell you about whether your sub
stoichiometric or not.
And then adding a time dimension.
So basically the same thing, mall as a
product per mole catalyst per second.
And you'll see there's,
you can hit the full spectrum.
So there's really terrible catalysts
that could do one turnover per day.
And there's really amazing catalyst.
I think the record for synthetic catalysts
are the ones that are used in polymer
synthesis.
So converting ethane into polyethylene.
These catalysts can do
millions of turnovers per hour.
And then along these lines you
have to think about safety.
Sometimes there are cases we're doing
millions of turnovers and an hour might be
generating dangerous pressure
or dangerous temperature.
So all of these things have to
be taken into consideration.
And then end of life. I already
mentioned the pharmaceutical issues,
but just in general,
can you reuse the catalyst and can you
separate it from product mixture? Uh, it,
it can be very difficult,
especially if you're, um,
your catalyst has a very small particle
size and we're starting to see some
innovations and things like attaching
and catalysts and magnetic beads.
So here's a photo of a chemical reaction.
The catalyst is all
dispersed and the solution,
and it's probably too small so that you
wouldn't be able to filter this very
effectively.
But by applying the magnet here,
they've caused all the catalyst to lump
up on the side there and then you can
just sort of pour off your,
your, uh, product and extra.